[Musique]
le projet de loi que le sénat examine à
partir de ce jeudi soir
répond avant tout à une urgence il faut
agir l'apparition du variant delta
depuis quelques jours montre bien que la
pandémie n'a pas encore touché à sa fin
la seule réponse médicale actuelle et la
vaccination et j'y suis très favorable
je le dis depuis des mois et que toutes
celles et tous ceux qu'ils puissent se
faire vacciner le fasse me semble est
une nécessité que le personnel soignant
soient vaccinés et l'obligation d'être
actionnée relève du bon sens ensuite il
va y avoir le débat sur les libertés
individuelles et peut-être que le
conseil constitutionnel pourrait être
saisie sur eux tel ou tel sujet en tout
cas il faut raison garder aucun texte de
loi n'arrivera à combattre la pandémie
de façon informelle avec un arrêt
certains cela relève bien également de
la responsabilité de chacun et donc
évidemment je vous appelle à continuer à
être vigilant tout seul mois d'août et
et tout cet été face à la pandémie
prenez soin de vous à très bientôt
[Musique]